SpaceX founder Elon must successfully
launch the Falcon Heavy rocket and this
is the part that it's just captured my
imagination I think it's probably the
same for a lot of people the rockets
carrying a Tesla Roadster into orbit
between the Earth and Mars a Tesla car
this is real footage I couldn't put this
is actual real footage that's real he
put that is a red Tesla Roadster and
they put a astronaut in like a dummy
like Anakin a mannequin it's just very
cool now I saw that and I've always
wanted to break barriers on my show okay
and I thought this is number four
thousand we really got to do something
but I'll be honest today I don't have
nearly the money to send a Tesla tamar's
I don't have that kind of kind of
scratch but ladies and gentlemen we
thought about it and if you're creative
you can do anything we're gonna do the
next best thing
okay we can't put a Tesla into Mars or
but we can put a mars bar in a Tesla
there is ladies and gentlemen there is
Nikola Tesla the great engineer inventor
and physicist many people think he died
in 1943 but he is alive and well and
with us tonight and he's holding a mars
bar that's right Tesla is holding a Mars
bar we have dozens of cameras to grab
all the action this is very
sophisticated
we've prepared by running thousands of
simulations I think he's going to
attempt it very soon maybe now you're
witnessing history and here he goes
this is Tesla getting a Mars bar he's
getting he's getting it he's getting it
and he's gonna it's getting in there
it's gonna
they're celebrating in Mission Control
right now
[Applause]
is this amazing Andy you know what it
makes me proud to be an American when my
grandkids asked me where I was when they
put a Mars in Tesla I am gonna say
choose me Andy Andy I'm sorry
it looks like nikola tesla is choking on
the mars bar he's only got a few minutes
before he passes out completely I'm told
Mission Control was sending help right
now to Nikola Tesla here comes the help
command of Thomas Brooklyn is going to
perform a daring mix catch Heimlich
maneuver he's going to perform a
Heimlich maneuver mid sketch hunt - wait
a minute he's moving away very slowly I
don't know why he's moving away as
Tesla's dying why would he move he's got
an American flag he wants to plant the
flag commander you don't have time you
don't have time you've got to drop the
flag and save Tesla drop the flag and
save Tesla that's right give me Heimlich
maneuver he's giving Tesla - uber
[Applause]
Nikola Tesla it's a thank you
sit back down on Mission Control
[Applause]
everybody's excited we have we have a
show worthy of that kind of comedy
tonight ladies and gentlemen from
Silicon Valley the what Andy what are
you doing
the stupid show always was always will
be
you